[Musique]
ce sont des rencontres informel sous la
forme de portes ouvertes au sein de nos
agences ou alors d'afterwork et ça
permet aux candidats de rencontrer nos
managers nos directeurs et nos chargés
de recrutement c'est l'occasion pour
nous d'expliquer les métiers du groupe
d'expliquer les profils que nous
recherchons et aussi de commencer à
parler de parcours de carrière avec ses
futurs potentiels
collaborateurs
nous recherchons 50 profils
aéronautiques en île-de-fance en CDI
nous recherchons des profils d'ouvriers
qualifiés et de techniciens notamment
des ajusteurs monteurs des câurs des
approvisionneurs nous recherchons aussi
des profils ingénieurs notamment des
chefs de projet ou des ingénieurs
qualité pour accompagner notre
développement ça se passera donc demain
mardi 14 novembre de 17h à 20h au Jungle
arch qui est un bar qui se trouve à
Nanterre justement on aime cette
proximité avec les candidats et avoir
cet échange dans un lieu externe pour
renforcer la l'échange informel
j'encourage donc toutes celles et ceux
qui sont intéressés au juste curieux par
le secteur aéronautique à nous rejoindre
demain à en savoir plus sur nos métiers
à en savoir plus sur l'évolution de
l'aéronautique et peut-être à envisager
une carrière chez Segula
[Musique]
technologie